and so we'll add to it so I like always
tend to introduce something and then we
build on that okay um so in this drill
he he's going to be the person I'm
responding to okay so if he pushes on me
I don't want to brace against him he
pushes and I let myself move and I take
it into a turn he pushes again let
myself move and I take it into a turn
when he pushes on me
I don't want to cross my
legs he pushes and I try to keep my base
as neutral as possible keeping mindful
that that foot is never way behind my
head goes I take it into a
TR okay so he goes again I don't want to
do this I don't want to be late
I let him push and I just turn pushes
and I
turn pushes and I
turn okay let's try it again let's go
on so he's going to drive I'm going to
take in essence Ido ten con take this
head marck and just keep
kneeling I get
down I'm inside his GID space so he's
got that hand there don't try to shove
against the hand when he comes in I
might angle then I can come
in
tap when you end up one leg forward
other knee up so you have weights on
him and you have a good wide base you're
here like
this all right let's try it nice and
slow at first okay let's watch a little
closer it's a kind Tami waza so I have
of course he's pushing that's what makes
the
yield so that's what makes me go here
and you're going to lose your balance
you just keep turning till you lose your
balance if you try to not lose your
balance that's what makes it award
let yourself release into the P try
as he pushes my technique is very
soft
okay this
leg is to support me he tries to just
push me that way he's really strong can
hold him down this leg he tries to throw
me over his head which I'll show you
that later you don't want to be like
this it's very easy to just roll
make so
base careful how much you lean over here
as you're very weak this way and you're
going
over keep
going my weight is kind of on this
diagonal of his
ribs here like this okay not like that
you're going to go
over okay that is what Tyler was asking
about that point of no reer okay just go
slow and smooth and relax okay try
to
okay in the same
way that he accepts my push he goes with
it you see and in the same way he
accepts his
falling I accept I'm being taken down
because I have to think on the
Fly and I don't want this arm out here
okay if you can get my triceps and hold
this here I am in a lot worse position
okay so as we're falling
I have to try to pull my elbow back in I
drive good and I'm trying to drive that
elbow in near me so if he tries to pull
it it's very hard because it's an
anchored elbow
okay TR again I
dve except that I got taken down already
on the Flor start
thinking don't let this happen Okay pull
that elbow in Anchor it so we'll try
that
try when your
T you give him Ledges he can trap things
easier okay so if he drives it on tense
you have to make big external movement
to get all the way
around but if you're
loose you can fit in that
spot it didn't even have to move
okay
likewise when he
goes and you're freaking out you're
going to get intense and this arm is
going to get stuck in there you see
stuck in there he's
even though my arm is currently
bent the elbow is in katame he has the
technique go ahead into it see he's got
it and now he can keep me flat on my
back this is very difficult to get out
of so when I push and he goes look how I
fit your elbow is too low for him come
around see you can
see is too low and too
anchored he is much stronger than me and
he tries to extend that pick it up it's
too
hard if it was here that's that in
essence move your arm that is
K okay it has to be here below it cannot
be here might as well be nothing he's
going to punch me in the face there's
not much I can do okay so watch where I
start to fit in
there he's going around there it is
right
there okay and you just go
down and fit inside that you're fine
here and now can be on my
side
okay we'll do it again
I
drive right there he
goes easy peasy
okay you have to be relaxed to fit into
the in space if you have tension which
you might because you're losing or
you're being thrown then things get
stuck okay try it
again
okay so as he pushes I'm very lock so I
can fit in
there and as I push and he goes like I
just fit right
in Easy Peasy
okay I don't want to be flat on my back
he wants to flatten me on my back that's
why I don't want to give him that arm
cuz he can pull it flatten me so I keep
this
here if you happen to be flat on your
back get off your back turn on to your
side okay we're going to come over here
and use this
elbow in the C
extension
okay don't push don't use Muscle just
hold this I don't want him getting
heavier by coming towards me okay if he
were to let go come
out and lean on
that he can put his whole body on it do
a pushup on
it that's what I'm doing he puts his
chest on
it this is what I'm doing
okay but at a corner of his body so I'm
here it's very relaxed
okay this will help me not get my arm
pulled cuz I'm anchoring it here on this
scrip but it can also reinforce this
especially if he tries to go around the
Leever Le
Point again with your C there is no
leverage point so he goes doesn't do
anything but you can do it here okay
once you get here move where you can
move I can't move into him so I move
away from
him and as I move away from him I fill
the in space with
him push his head
into the leg come up the weak part of
the grit or entirely out from under
it bottom leg in front and
over extend your legs extend your spine
choke and
Crush
here if I'm flat turn on my
side Pokey extension
reinforce move out of the way move him
into the in space secure the
position up if you can go under go under
if you can't break through the two hands
bottom leg forward and over extend the
heels extend the
spine crush and choke nice and slow on
the submission quick on the tap okay sir
let's try it
okay let's try
and he's pushing and I would move into
this all this space that is yet so I go
inside his grip around his head behind
his
body I
don't push
him hit
him pull him I have to move around the y
space okay so when he's
here you're going to want to go like
that don't do
that all I'm doing is stopping him from
coming forward okay don't push past that
here then move you and he'll fall into
that spot that's enough okay then just
hold him there same thing don't shove
him just hold him there try to come back
forward can't do
it okay then this leg goes around in the
free space and I go in the free
space and
mouth if he's holding this
grip don't try to break it it's fine you
still have the crush and the choke
so think of it as a physical
puzzle where can I
move without
any
tension okay so let's not defend
ourselves anymore let's just make a game
out of it like a maze there's a wall
here go around the energy okay don't try
to push the Wall go around it that's our
game okay try it
again
one than he
goes and you might not want to get in
the ground fight with the
dude you should
always seek to stand up
Thena is a had to okay with the mind
that he has to make me stay down he's
not going to make me stay down and I'm
up so I push he
[Music]
goes I'm here you you get control first
and then side what you want to do
unfurl hips
down and now you can get up do it
again I'm
here
unfurl change
hips you can go from
here side but in our
exercise we're just going to stand up
one more time
from here
unfurl here he's going to relax As I
push
up okay more
releasing try it go
so I push it
goes
yield
unfurl when you're here
trade your hip that leg still on him do
you see yes sir
chest okay we're going to push
up to this
knee all my weight is here on that
diaphragm okay here you you have your
strikes you can go to mouth but I just
want you to feel this way everything is
relaxed if he can't take it he'll tap
and then you got to come off
okay
again we were
here unfr the bottom
line put your weight on
him push up put your weight on him okay
let's try it go watch this weight
P okay so I push she goes
this leg stays
on sit
up it's not just light down reach
across sit
up my weight's on
him sit up Waits on him sit up Waits on
him waights on him you see that
difference yes sir careful when you're
putting weight on the ground it's a
different kind
of
unacceptance okay put your weight on him
leg chest hands knee there was no mat
weight okay try it again
energy so as I push and he
goes just goes right into it you go
right into
it okay try not to stop it and zigzag it
we're all going in One
Direction I
drive okay and you're here try go so you
have a
couple antil clothing techniques
I come
up he tries to push my knee off of him
well the face is very open okay so you
kind of that's what this is creating a
dilemma are you going to guard your face
or are you going to try to Grapple more
okay he goes to Grapple more boom he'll
let go okay you can do elbows all that
so I do my elbows he starts to guard his
face now
you see how create this angle
cancellation
there another one sorry another one is
he goes to
grab you see Finding in space it's not
this way it's here come out this way
High
Step always turn
away from the hook this way you has a
good
one it's very very hard to hold that
just High Step and yank it with all your
okay so that's what we're going to
do boom there's my spot p and I come out
this
way or I come I try to come out that way
Escape
hooks come on out okay F your move can't
be in after his move your move is within
his move okay
so if he pops up gets the knee on me and
I start turning what's what's he going
to do boom you're going to stop turning
okay what you're doing instead
Swit is as he
goes you're gone you're not there you
see yes sir okay that's when I grab and
he also shouldn't wait for full
fruition okay so we
trade he's not going to wait for that if
if I get any of that neon That Elbow is
coming right in his face okay so he
moves at this part and I move at that
part okay then just hips he's flat and
you're
in one more
time in relax hug no space No Escape
okay no weights on him you're just
chilling
okay let's go ADM his move try
back we can start from here I go one he
goes I drop okay and I'm here
and got him in that move I didn't want
him to get in okay hold this tight hold
your
leg weight's the same but he can't turn
onto his side so he's just flat hanging
up there
okay one more
time I push I go he defend
spraw this elbows
up
pocket
underneath attaching to your leg to
secure your grip pull tight pin and
you're just hanging out here
okay try